the war in ukraine has pushed up the
price of all to a 10-year high with
russia under sanctions prices could
continue to go higher so how will the
world deal with this energy crisis this
is inside story
[Music]
hello welcome to the program i'm hasam
seeker as the russian invasion of
ukraine enters its second week crude oil
prices have risen to levels not seen in
a decade russia is the world's third
largest oil producer and provider of
nearly 40 percent of europe's energy
supplies prompting many to look for
alternatives
big energy consumers are boycotting
russian crude collapsing their demand as
they shun the country's market energy
markets have largely been spared from
the sanctions western countries placed
on russia's financial sector knowing how
important energy is to their own
economies despite the rise in prices
opec and other oil producing countries
said they are sticking with their plan
to gradually increase oil production
meanwhile nations including the us have
agreed to release 60 million barrels of
crude oil reserves it is hoped the
increase in supply will curb oil prices
after russia's invasion of ukraine the
price of crude is expected to hit more
than 120 dollars a barrel this weekend
and the increase is already causing long
queues of pumps in some regions of the
world
our eu energy ministers say they want to
speed up their transition to clean
energy sources europe
europe can cope in the event that there
is a cut in the supply of gas or oil
from russia we can do it immediately
however we will have to look in the
medium term at how to build new stocks
for next winter by first looking at how
to diversify our supply then by
replacing our strategic stocks again and
using our strategic stocks but also by
generally increasing our imports 4.6
percent
we are four to six percent dependent on
russian gas 30 dependent on russian oil
and 20 dependent on russian uranium so
it's clear that if we want to eliminate
this dependency we will have to
accelerate our energy transition heat
our homes differently and generate our
electricity differently
the most important agenda point is our
support
to ukraine
in this perspective
i expect that energy ministers will
support
the
emergency
synchronization of ukraine power creed
to with european creed as soon as
possible
i believe that this is
only
possibility at current circumstances
well let's get the thoughts of our
guests now joining us from london is
alex schindler president
of energy intelligence and the former
editor of petroleum intelligence weekly
in oslo we have bjorn shale drop a
specialist on european energy politics
and joining us from washington ben cane
hill sorry ben cahill senior fellow at
the energy security and climate change
program at the center for strategic and
international studies good to have you
all with us so um uh alex schindler if i
could start with you then uh what sort
of implications is all of this having
for the russian economy first of all the
longer this goes on
well thanks for having me on um
i mean the the impact on the russian
economy is already beginning to be felt
um
as you said yet in the opening parts the
sanctions have excluded energy uh for
the moment which is a large chunk of the
russian budget
but we already know that uh ordinary
russians and and very wealthy russians
have been hit by these sanctions by the
evaluation of google by the problems of
the stock market
so there's no doubt that these sanctions
are being felt in russia both by the
government and by ordinary people
beyond shale drop we we mentioned there
how dependent uh so many european
countries are on on russian
energy and there was there were there
had been quite a uneasiness about that
before this conflict started this has
now forced them uh to rethink things a
lot more quickly now hasn't it
absolutely i mean if you look back over
the past 20-30 years the idea was that
that europe the western europe should go
hand in hand to get with russia into the
future we should buy uh energy from
russia and they would get money from us
happy marriage and that marriage is now
broken totally and we saw like 180
degree turn by germany last week from
long-term supporter of importing russian
energy suddenly they just turned around
and say now we're going to build lng
import terminals they have none today
we're going to move away from this
energy marriage with with them
with russia and of course you know we
have a huge reliance on energy from
russia today in western europe so we
cannot really break the the marriage
apart quite yet but i i think the
divorce is clear and you know this is
going to accelerate western europe's uh
path towards renewable energy electric
vehicles and less dependence especially
on russian fossil fuels
ben cahill how much damage could this do
to the world economy because uh with the
economic sanctions that we've seen so
far from the united states and from from
their partners in europe we've seen them
kind of pull their punches a bit when it
comes to energy because they know
uh how much it's it's how much it could
affect them the economic blowback of
this on them uh potentially so so how
much what is the impact of this going
forward um and if things don't change
could they rethink that strategy of of
uh not doing anything to upset the
energy markets at this point
the economic stakes are really high and
this is one of the biggest energy
disruptions that we've seen since the
oil shocks of the 70s
and the backdrop of this of course is
that
in the united states and in a lot of
western economies we've had inflation
we've had pretty serious price run-ups
commodity prices have been rising for
the last six months as a result of this
really rapid rebound in commodity demand
for oil natural gas and other products
with the rebound from coca-19 and they
think it's taking governments by
surprise it's a big political liability
for the white administration and others
it's a huge economic challenge to deal
with it
um
and you know even before this past week
with the war
things were getting difficult to manage
from a political perspective
but here in washington the concern is
always about gasoline prices and how
presidents can manage that the reality
is that if you're in the white house you
don't have great options to deal with
rising energy prices
and the latest
conflict the war that russia has entered
into with ukraine has just kind of turbo
charged all these concerns alex
schindler if i could turn back to you on
this um i mean i put this question to
bjorn earlier is this going to speed up
efforts to
diversify
energy dependence from a lot of
countries
well i think what we've heard is that
many european leaders would like it to
and they're going to make efforts to do
it i think the important thing to note
is the bigger picture here
um while in the short term the ability
to get europe uh
not dependent on russia
is is not possible
in the short term but the bigger picture
here what we're witnessing
is a division between
uh europe and russia and i think as the
previous guest said or the previous
speaker said a break in this marriage
um and so europe has got to find other
alternatives they're making decisions
right now that will force them to do so
so whether they're going to be able to
find alternative gas supplies from other
places they're 40 dependent on russian
gas whether they're going to find um
rethink their nuclear stance as there's
been some indication that some countries
are doing or whether they're going to
try to speed up the transition to a
lower carbon economy by
rushing through renewables and other
new energy sources um
this is the longer term direction of
travel but i would 100 agree this is not
going to be possible to do right away so
it will be tough in the short term to
deal with a disruption if russian energy
no longer flows to europe
uh beyond shelter how could this how bad
could this get for you because history
has shown that whenever there's been a a
large spike in oil prices not long after
that there's been uh quite a large
recession
yeah i think you know that it's
increasing risk that this is going to
have an extremely negative out uh
fallout for the global economy and
especially for the european economy and
if you look at natural gas prices right
now they're in europe they are trading
at equivalent of 300 per barrel of oil
equivalent versus normal 35 to 40 right
so we are talking
eight nine ten times
the normal price in europe and with also
higher prices in asia for natural gas
and of course you know the market is
pricing that these prices are going to
be where they are now at 300 all through
the year until the q1 i think that is
totally unsustainable this is is
breaking a demand down and prices will
have to fall back and and of course when
you break demand you basically
essentially break the economy and of
course you know it's not just natural
gas but also coal prices are five times
higher than normal they increased 50
yesterday
and not just for the front end but also
for an uh december contract later this
year and so you know it's rippling and
casting cascading through the global
economy
and we use so much energy for so many
things and everything will go increasing
in cost industrial metals are moving
straight up due to the increased cost
but also agricultural products are
moving straight up the ladder with the
highest price ever in nominal terms for
the agriculture product index of
bloomberg
ben cahill um
how bad could this get for the u.s
economy the longer this goes on you
mentioned uh you know higher prices at
the pumps that's that's going to affect
many americans more more directly but
the longer with the other problems that
the u.s economy and other economies are
facing right now with inflation and
trying to get
uh trying to recover from uh
from from the long pandemic the the
effects of that um how bad could this
get the longer this goes on for
america
i think inflation is an economy-wide
problem in the united states not just in
the energy sector but for all kinds of
goods you go out to dinner you see
the price of food has increased the cost
of everything seems to be going up i
think this is the number one political
challenge for the white house and energy
is a huge part of it
you know consumer prices are increasing
around seven seven and a half percent a
month most of us have never seen this
kind of inflation in our lifetimes
and you know the old adage about
gasoline prices is that
people feel it every time they feel the
pump because they see the numbers and
they see them ticking up it's a very
visible sign of the inflation that they
feel all around them so the white house
is really keenly focused on this it's
been a huge challenge for them since the
fall
we saw that the white house started to
experiment with you know using the
strategic petroleum reserves last
november to try to put more barrels on
the market cool the market let's talk
over and over again about trying to have
dialogue with opec and the other oil
producers to encourage them to ramp up
production
and the reality is you know this is a
white house that i think doesn't really
want to talk about it they want to talk
about the energy transition they want to
talk about pushing that forward
um but energy security issues have come
back in a big way in the past six months
and so they're trying to keep their eyes
on the horizon with the longer term
energy transition issues that they care
so passionately about trying to push
those forward but the reality of the
market is intervening that things of
course have gotten much worse in the
last week
alex schindler we mentioned at the top
there how opec for now is going to stick
to its current uh policy of of not
opening up the taps further to try and
bring bring the pressure uh down and
increase supply and thereby uh hopefully
lower the prices what's the thinking uh
behind that and what are the the kind of
geopolitical implications as well
uh with with the biden administration
yeah it's a great question i mean i
think as many viewers may know we had a
meeting of opec this week
they decided to
have a very quick meeting
and basically keep production policy the
same
now another thinking as we understand it
is they really didn't think there's much
value in adding additional oil to this
market
and because from their view
a lot of the sort of fraud from the
prices coming from the geopolitical
premium in this war
and their experience and there's a lot
of experienced people that are leading
opec countries now tells them that
adding additional barrels in the market
that's uh you know facing a crisis is
not always the recipe to kind of bring
prices down to get to ben's point to
reducing prices to pump that often is
not a correlation there especially in
the middle of a crisis
so they felt first of all there wasn't
much points in adding additional barrels
they also it's important to point out
you know russia
is a key member of the opec alliance
that's been managing markets
for a number of years now
and they also did not want to get into
the discussion uh with russia or other
member states about whether it's
appropriate to be raising a changing
output right now because once you start
talking about it it starts getting
complicated and they did not want to be
part of the story so the strategy was
quick uh continuation of policy was
already announced to get it over with
and don't become the story because they
do not want to become part of this giant
story that's dominating headlines right
now which is the ukraine war
um
beyond shale drop is there a fear as
well that by um uh increasing supply
right now it could come back to bite
them and in that later on you'll get a
glut in the markets and that'll bring
oil prices too low too low too low that
they like
right i mean if we look at the bread
crude oil spot price today it traded as
high as
177 dollars per barrel and i think sort
of um this of course oil price is
hitting uh wide across the world for
consumers everywhere while while not gas
prices so far hitting predominantly
asian and european consumers um and i
think you know versus historical levels
demand destruction for oil is starting
to bite
from 120 to 150 dollars per barrel so
we're starting to make destruction on
the demand side with current oil prices
and and i think um
opec would very much like to avoid a
boom and then a bust they would like to
avoid that current spike in energy and
metals and agriculture prices
basically it tips the global economy
into recession so i think yes um
russia and saudi arabia have a very very
important relationship and and saudi is
is very reluctant to step in and meddle
in the whole thing and add more barrels
in the middle of the crisis but you know
if if oil price continues to 130 100 450
you know i think yeah the equation
becomes slightly different because then
the risk or recession really increases
could significantly and these boom burst
cycles this is not really what you want
as an oil producers they really would
like to be
more stable um but uh avoiding these
boom busts so so that could change the
equation bit
ben cahill what's your view on that
i think it's a tough position for oprah
foster right
their stated goal is to
avoid volatility in the market as beyond
said
um
and the backdrop of this is that
spare capacity within the group is
pretty limited you know if we take a
step back in april of 2020 opec plus
made the biggest production cuts ever
you know they responded to the price
crash that happened all the concerns
after coca-19 they cut 9.7 million
dollars a day for the market
ever since month by month they've been
adding barrels in
and what they've said is that they're
hoping to balance supply and demand they
don't want to move too quickly and put
too many barrels onto the market they do
see some potential downside risks
the issue here is that as they've added
more oil onto the market each month the
wedge of available spare capacity has
gotten smaller and smaller and in a
tight market like this with a lot of
concerns about low inventories
you know pretty strong demands
people are worried about low spare
capacity so in addition to the question
of whether or not it would really help
in the market to put barrels on
it's kind of a damned if you do them if
you don't situation you know if they put
more barrels under the market and
diminish their capacity it could
backfire in some ways
so
my read on the meeting this week is that
they needed a little bit more time to
digest what was happening and the scale
of the disruption from russia before
they take action i think another thing
at the back of their minds is that we
could have an iran deal happen at some
point very soon
and that would have a real material
impact on balances looking out for the
rest of this year
so i think there are some benefits wait
see how this unfolds and then maybe come
back and make a decision together at
some point soon
yeah let's put that to alex schindler i
mean ben cahill there was talking about
if there's a possibility of reviving the
2015 nuclear uh iran nuclear deal and
the potential of bringing iran
back into the into the oil market uh
what what effect could that have
well it would have a major effect and
and so what we are
hearing is that we are quite close
to a deal being agreed between
the us and western powers and iran to
reinstate the nuclear deal that former
president donald trump walked away from
and this would be a significant addition
of oil to the market from what we
understand that the opec meeting this
was not a
a point of discussion really they kind
of just wanted to get it finished as
soon as possible not discuss very much
at all and their policy is they don't
really talk about what's going to happen
in the future but but a return of iran
at least from a sentiment point of view
even the understanding that iran barrels
are coming back to the market depending
how quickly they can actually do it
would potentially counteract some of
that sort of froth we're seeing in the
market which is which is getting quite
significant now i think we have to
remember that it's going to take months
to bring any iranian production back
i think the iranians hope that they can
move and add about one to one and a half
million barrels a day over the next
couple of months after the deal is
agreed and everything's signed off um
you know our experience with that is
that sometimes optimistic doesn't quite
all come back at that time so while the
announcement of a deal would be
from a sentiment point of view
potentially something that can
counteract the higher oil prices from a
physical supply point of view i think
people shouldn't get too excited about
this actually changing the equation what
we're talking about here
because as ben says we're having there's
not quite enough will to sort of fill
this market um and the extra barrels now
back and forth you know are getting
smaller and smaller
um beyond shale drop a lot of people
have been saying that the the war in
ukraine may have a limited impact on the
on the global economy right now because
trade links uh with russia and the rest
of the world were limited to begin with
with uh with russia accounting for
something like 1.5
of joe global gdp
uh so with that in mind then what um
what potential impact do you think there
could be both on on russia's economy and
and the rest of the world
well i mean as long as energy prices are
low we tend to forget that it matters
right it's kind of off the chart out of
mind and and we don't notice how
incredibly important energy and food is
before prices starts to rise
significantly and of course russia is
massively important for the global
energy market
especially for european and general for
the global market but but we must also
remember that um russia is a very large
exporter of aluminum
and palladium and nickel
and a lot of other resources as well and
and not to forget russia is the biggest
number one wheat exporter in the world
and ukraine is number number five and
together russia and ukraine export more
wheat from the so-called bread basket
and black earth
black sea region and they are bigger
together than uh united states and
canada together so you know when it
really [ __ ] hits the fan and and and you
really want energy you want food of
course russia is massively important
just a short comment on on on crude
barrels from from opec plus you know
what we see here is a squeeze that
started
in the natural gas market with light
molecules and this typically has has
cascaded into a tight market for light
sweet crude typically brent crude and
vti
and the crude that opec plus typically
have and that russia also typically has
is is um is medium heavy and sour crude
so
this is not the biggest shortage the
biggest shortage is in the light end of
the spectre for lightsweight crude and
that is leading the rally but of course
now we're losing something like one to
two million barrels per day from russia
in terms of crude oil sour medium sour
crude and and
and that is of course tightening up that
part of the market which of course the
rest of opec plus could help to to
alleviate so so that would be good but
but you know right now it's a an
exporter strike in terms of all crude
barrels out of of russia it seems with
shippers not wanting to take the cargo's
refineries not wanting to take the oil
so even if oil in and energy is not
sanctioned for exports out of russia in
practical terms we actually see a sharp
reduction of flows of uh both coal and
oil out of western russian ports uh ben
cahill uh bjorn mentioned there uh the
the the impact of uh of wheat uh we on
wheat supply so beyond oil we look at
other commodities like like wheat which
uh as we said russia and ukraine are
large suppliers of what what
implications or what impact could that
have on on the global markets
yeah i think beyond makes a good point
that russia is often thought of as an
exporter of oil and gas but in fact they
export a lot of
metals and agricultural commodities too
and so does ukraine by the way for both
the exporters of wheat
i think it adds to the inflationary
concerns that we see around the world
we've already had rising food prices in
a lot of places
you've got regions like the middle east
that are quite dependent on grant
imports so it's going to add to some of
that
economic pressure
and just to back up something that that
bjorn said i mean i think
when we look at the shortages today
we see an immediate impact with fruit
but some of these other commodity
commodities are raw inputs and kind of
base materials that are used in
manufacturing and
lots of other things so the impacts and
the potential price impact we're not
going to see it necessarily today we'll
continue to unfold over a couple months
all right we're going to have to leave
it there thank you to all three of you
alex chandela bjorn shell drop and ben
cahill thanks very much for being on
inside story
and thank you as always for watching
remember you can see this program again
anytime just go to our website
aljazeera.com and for further discussion
go to our facebook page that's
facebook.com forward slash aj inside
story you can also join the conversation
on twitter our handle there is at aj
inside story from me has some seeker and
the whole team here in doha bye for now
[Music]